[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 en
chile tras más de 5 años de tramitación
el matrimonio igualitario podría ser
pronto una realidad aunque el presidente
sebastián piñera se mostró durante la
campaña electoral contrario al
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
en su última cuenta pública sorprendió a
la oposición y también al oficialismo al
anunciar que pondría suma urgencia a un
proyecto que fue ingresado al congreso
en 2017 durante el segundo gobierno de
michelle bachelet
el matrimonio igualitario es un paso
adelante por las paternidades
responsables y hacia la comprensión de
las familias como unos núcleos diversos
en los que la salud física y mental no
depende de la orientación sexual de sus
integrantes si se aprueba en chile-
sentará un precedente regional y también
cambiará la vida de personas como
cristian y rodrigo pues ambos podrían
ser ante la ley y los padres de sus tres
hijos adoptados en la actualidad sólo
uno de ellos es reconocido como papá
legal de los niños
para mí está en el papá de abril le
vengo a decir que me gustó en su familia
en colina y me gustan modélica son muy
lindos en me gusta que tenga dos papas
el día que ya no hay de siete años y la
mayor de tres hermanos huérfanos supo
que iba a ser adoptada no mostró
sorpresa sino felicidad ante la idea de
tener dos papás la vida de los hermanos
o adoptados cambió radicalmente pero
mucho más cambió la de cristian y
rodrigo pareja por 18 años que vivieron
un tsunami emocional con la llegada a
sus vidas de tres niños de siete seis y
cuatro años
teníamos un bar donde recibían a
nuestros amigos y ahora se transformó en
una zona de juegos así que fue
un
resumen completo de nuestra vida donde
había al bar ahora hay una zona de
juegos la pareja tuvo que romper su
acuerdo de unión civil para que uno de
ellos cristian pudiera adoptar a los
niños como soltero la ley china no
permite la adopción monoparental aunque
la práctica las propias instituciones
estatales circunvala en la normativa con
registros desde al menos el 2017 la
región metropolitana hay 45 niños que
viven en familias homoparentales o lejos
maternales además de todas las que hay
en regiones además de todos los niños
que nacen en familias lejos maternales
que es algo más común cristian y rodrigo
han hecho de su caso un icónico
visibilizando en redes sociales su
historia que se ha traducido en una
labor de derribar mitos y en más
solicitudes en los orfanatos públicos de
personas solteras o de familias diversas
que nos mueve es el amor y eso es la
esencia de una familia es el amor
entonces
basta poder señalar eso y demostrarlo
para que todos se den cuenta que las
familias homoparentales si son
familias legítimas y además podemos
tener hijos y podemos educar y criar los
prejuicios son de los mayores que los
transforman en positivo yo he visto a la
más grande de nuestra hija que le
comenta la profesora vía a su profesora
yo tengo en vez de un papá tengo dos
para mañana aquí para ya lo máximo como
estas a volar la lotería con dos papás
la conclusión de ambos sobre su
experiencia es apoteósica
estos 18 años ha sido nuestro momento
más importante en nuestra vida y nos
proyectamos el futuro de los cinco con
felicidad fuera
después de ver el informe de nuestra
corresponsal en chile patricia luna
ahora la conversación sobre este tema es
con isabel amour directora ejecutiva de
la fundación iguales y quién se conecta
con nosotros desde santiago de chile
isabel bienvenida a ellas hoy y para
empezar porque sebastián piñera cambió
de postura y decidió impulsar este
proyecto en el último tramo de su
mandato lo que sí es que chile sin duda
vive un momento para la historia entre
otras cosas con la constituyente que
también sería fundamental para los
derechos de todos los ciudadanos
muchísimas gracias por esta invitación
efectivamente un cambio de postura por
parte del presidente piñera y este
cambio de postura edad creo yo que tiene
que ver con con un proceso en que el
presidente decide dejar una marca en la
historia de chile una marca que unifica
la familia y unifica el país hoy el
matrimonio igualitario en un movimiento
que ha sido permanente durante los
últimos 10 años tiene una mayoría de
aprobación tanto en la población chilena
como en en el congreso en ambas cámaras
por tanto es una medida que puede
sacarse adelante sebastián piñera puede
anotarse a la historia de chile como el
presidente que sacó en la ley de
identidad de género y el presidente que
también sacaría matrimonio igualitario
el matrimonio o parental isabel es un
triunfo para los derechos humanos más
aún para nosotras en el entendimiento de
que el feminismo busca la equidad para
todos y para todas como la aprobación
del matrimonio igualitario nos aleja de
una sociedad fálica y machista
en primera medida y yo creo que es
importante y esto lo subrayó cada vez
que puedo dar cuenta que el movimiento
de diversidad sexual y de género solo
existe gracias al movimiento feminista
es el feminismo quien nos otorga una
batería conceptual y práctica también
para poder ir disolviendo algunas ideas
preconcebidas de lo que es la familia de
lo que tiene que ser y los roles de
género y de cómo nos vamos a conducir en
sociedad entonces eso lo quisiera
recalcar muchísimo y por otra parte me
parece que el matrimonio es una de las
instituciones
más conservadoras y más queridas por la
gente
que defiende una sociedad sin equidad de
género y por tanto que las parejas del
mismo sexo
accedan al matrimonio igualitario hace
un hacer mella en el conservadurismo en
términos generales en término específico
el matrimonio el estéreo en chile
incluye filiación y por tanto los hijos
e hijas de familia del que están
compuestas por dos madres o dos padres
serán
iguales ante la ley en la protección de
sus hijos e hijas no esto es una
cuestión muy importante porque en chile
tal como lo
demostraron lo mostraban en su nota hay
cientos de familias y cientos de niños
que están en absoluta desprotección
respecto a los derechos que tienen que
tener
es un derecho común y corriente del
derecho a la identidad el derecho al
cuidado la protección al hogar a la
familia etcétera etcétera estos son
derechos de todos los niños niñas y
adolescentes por tanto no hay ninguna
justificación concreta por la cual el
estado chileno y los estados de
latinoamérica
tengan
la capacidad real de poder quitarles
todo derecho al niño y además es que
usted lo está diciendo con las uniones
de parejas de diversas pues también se
abren las posibilidades
homoparentales que tradicionalmente
estaban en edad solamente para las
mujeres teníamos la obligación de parir
y de criar y sólo nosotras por esta
supuesta condición natural en la que
eventualmente nos acompañaría un hombre
para hacer un proveedor todo esto ya
está mandado y ximo a recoger y aquí
estamos hablando es de personas que
crían a sus hijos con amor con respeto
con responsabilidad con cargas
compartidas como esto mejora gracias a
este avance en la ley en chile
en términos concretos
el matrimonio es la institución que más
protege a la familia y más protege a los
a este núcleo no entonces en esto no se
trata únicamente de pensar que claro en
las parejas del mismo sexo tanto de dos
hombres de dos mujeres
la responsabilidad se se va equiparando
no se trata de poder
entender que las familias se hacen de
manera diversa y por tanto y esto es
bien importante decirlo las mujeres
muchas de nosotras queremos formar
familias con hijos podemos hacerlo
porque finalmente nuestro cuerpo también
lo permite pero hay siempre una madre o
un padre que no tiene la la posibilidad
de cuidar a su hijo oa su hija conforme
corresponde entonces aquí lo que estamos
haciendo es dar cuenta de que existen
otras familias y esas familias tienen
que ser merecedoras de todos los
derechos sin discriminación alguna
que tanto ya para cerrar muy rápidamente
los niños se están perdiendo la
oportunidad por ejemplo en chile de
crecer en un hogar amoroso y que les
brinde oportunidades por culpa de esta
sociedad nuestra tan homófoba tan
machista y que aún en el 2021 percibe la
masculinidad de una forma tan errada tan
tan discriminatoria tampoco para todo el
mundo
hoy en chile tenemos bueno aquí tenemos
los problemas el no reconocimiento
legal por parte de padres y madres que
son padres y madres y que el estado no
nos reconoce que están criando a esos
hijos
por ejemplo si yo y mi mujer tenemos un
hijo biológicamente el estado no
reconocería una de las dos probablemente
en este caso a mí por no hacer la madre
biológica y por tanto ese niño niña y
adolescente pierde por ejemplo derecho a
herencia derecho a la identidad familiar
y derecho a cuidado la posibilidad de
por ejemplo de mandarme por alimentos de
mandarme por visitas y un gran etcétera
ahora también están otros niños niños y
adolescentes que son parte en este
momento y muy lamentablemente del
sistema estatal de cuidado de infancias
en este entiende se llama sename sistema
nacional de menores y hoy las parejas
del mismo sexo no pueden acceder como
tales a la adopción cuestión que una que
no sólo discriminatoria para
para las parejas sino que también y
principalmente le quita posibilidades a
los niños niñas y adolescentes de tener
una familia a la brevedad entonces lo
que estamos haciendo con el matrimonio
igualitario es exigir el reconocimiento
de todas las familias en dar cuenta que
no podemos tener ciudadanos de primera y
de segunda categoría que vamos a hacer
además las mujeres gracias al impulso
tremendo que nos al feminismo quienes
saquemos adelante la bandera por nuestra
familia por nuestro hijo y por nuestro
reconocimiento
muchísimas gracias e isabella amores de
las fundaciones iguales nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy y sigan en
france 24
[Música]